uh rodney there's a lot to get to and
you and i had the conversation on pftpm
several weeks ago about
the realities of the pandemic and the
concerns that it will create for players
who find themselves in a locker room on
a practice field in a game
and you hit the nail on the head and
we've seen
25 or more players just this week decide
they're not going to play at all this
year including six members of the
patriots how surprised
were you by the developments i'm not
really surprised and this is i think
this is
really bad news for the national
football league and i applaud these
young men
leaving 8 million leaving millions of
dollars on the table
and understanding perspective
understanding what's important family
making sure that they don't you know do
anything to bring
something home to their kids i mean you
look at marcus cannon from the patriots
he's a cancer survivor hightower and
vitali
both have newborn babies you look at
patrick chung he has a baby on the way
so it's a lot of these dudes
um looking at their family situations
and saying look i love football
i've made a lot of money i'm financially
stable i'm a step away from the game a
year and and see what happens
uh rodney so all right let's just i want
you i want to hear your
you know your thought here cause i'm a
guy that's like
you know i would play if i didn't have
some huge health issue
you know you're right if my wife had a
child or something like that i don't
know maybe i would think about it
certainly then
but i want to know you rodney harrison
who i
know loves football like obsessed psycho
new england patriots do your job would
you play football in the 2020 season as
it sits right now
absolutely not now as much as i love
football i love my family a hundred
times more
and you know you look at a lot of these
players if they're financially
okay they don't mind sitting out they
don't mind because you think about a guy
like hightower
he's had some injuries this year gives
him the opportunity to sit out
rest his body rest his mental and figure
out what he wants to do for the rest of
his career
and here's the question though rodney
and chris and i were talking about this
earlier we know how football goes
if you're not there you're out of sight
you're out of mind the next man up gets
a chance to impress bill belichick
come next year when dante hightower
shows up with an 8 million
salary if the guy who takes his place
dollar for dollar
is better and we've seen belichick be
ruthless in that regard
he'll go with the younger guy he'll go
with the cheaper guy do you run the risk
of coming back to uh a job that's been
taken
next year mike they're gonna bring in
talent every single year they're always
bringing in
newer younger guys fresher guys to try
to steal your position to try to get
somebody cheaper at the end of the day
hightower's not worried about that if he
can leave eight million dollars on the
table
then i think he has a lot of money in
the bank and even more so than that it's
about your health
the most important thing is about your
health you can play another year of
football he could become a free agent
get released by the patriots and go sign
with the mommy dolphins for a 10 million
dollar signing bonus i don't worry about
the money for high tower
but i just applaud these young men for
stepping up and i do believe that during
the course of training camp and during
the course of the season
you're going to see more guys get
infected and you're going to see more
guys willing to walk away so
what does this mean for their defense in
new england i mean
you know listen i worked there and i
played against you know you guys you
were hurt once it's it's one of the more
complicated defenses in football right i
mean there's a lot of communication
i hear belichick talk all the time like
nobody knows the defense better than
you know hightower and and patrick chung
you know do
will this handicap them a little bit
about maybe the amount of defense or
things they'll do on the field rodney
well i mean i think they're going to
continue to do what they do
but when you don't have high tide when
you don't have patrick chung two guys
that are definitely talk about
communication
i think that's the strength of that
their defense and what they do is
communicate they do so many things
and you look at hightower hightower is
really an underrated guy
yeah he doesn't have great speed from
sideline to sideline but he's
very instinctual um this guy makes a lot
of big plays in the biggest moments of
the game he can blitz he can rush
off the edge you know he can drop in in
coverage
and you look at patrick chung patrick
chung has been one of the most versatile
one of the best defensive players in the
national football league what he meant
for the patriots over all these years
what he's been able to do
i tell you this chris without patrick
chung the patriots would have been
hard-pressed to win those super bowls
that he was involved in
and you know rodney here's the reality i
mean the patriots have been hit harder
than anyone with the opt out so far but
it seems to me there's no coach in the
nfl better suited
to roll with the punches next man up no
excuses no
woe is us we're going to plug these
holes we're going to coach these guys up
we're going to get them ready to go
do you expect when it's all said and
done a dramatic drop
off given that it's bill belichick
finding replacements getting those guys
in the best position possible they still
got cam newton
they still got other great players and
they still have bill belichick do you
think the patriots ultimately are going
to be affected by this in a negative way
um i think it's going to get take time
for their defense to get back to what it
was
last year because you're going to
incorporate some new guys you've lost
some guys
um but i still think this is going to be
a really good defense they have cohesion
in the secondary they have excellent
coaching
and i think belichick's going to keep it
relatively simple until guys are able
to pick up the system some of the new
young guys linebackers
um the young safety that came through i
think he's going to keep it simple and
allow those guys to play free and play
fast but the most important thing is
making sure that communication is on
point
and that you continue to develop depth
at all those defensive positions
all right hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports